all right you're done I hope you don't
mind that I gave you the larger table
this time but it depends on the first
one so it have been hard to give you it
in any other order I gave you the
content value structure so it's pretty
easy to just insert the data then we
query the data back out if move to first
fails the cursor is empty and the query
failed from lots of cut and paste here
it is nice to fetch the DB values using
the helper for the data type although
it's not strictly necessary since we
know our test data is actually going to
match our constraints and there is one
more failure case we need to add here if
our query doesn't return any rose that's
it all that just to get a database in a
way to test it now let's run the test
again well at least we know all the
basic stuff works and just remember
without these tests you would have been
able to run this code for a very very
long time